en voiture des familles sortent des
territoires
occupés
ces hommes sont les premiers soldats
Ukrainiens qu'elle voit depuis 7 mois
certains sont au bord des larmes
tous sont épuisés
c'est inimaginable c'est l'enfer mais on
est sorti on est resté au checkpoint
pendant 3 jours ils étaient en train de
tirer dans le coin le FSB nous a fait
faire demi-tour on a du tout recommencer
les hommes on le sentiment d'avoir
échappé un piège celui de la
mobilisation décrétée par Moscou
il mobilise déjà les jeunes de 18 à 35
ans là-bas il ne vous demande pas si
vous êtes volontaire ou non il vous
force il vous enrôlent
j'ai 50 ans Valérie a 59 ans aujourd'hui
ils enrôles jusqu'à 35 ans mais demain
ce sera 50 ils vont pousser tout le
monde dans la guerre et on ne veut pas
se battre contre l'Ukraine on est
patriote réfugié dans leur propre pays
ils rejoignent la ville de zaporigia
la capitale régionale est sous contrôle
ukrainien mais une partie de la région
est occupée
au lac bouriac et le chef de
l'administration militaire de la ville
tous les jours ils seront sur les lieux
ciblés par les frappes russes
ici un immeuble d'habitation
je suis sans abri je suis sans abri mon
3 pièces et totalement détruit
là c'est un missile solaire
techniquement fait pour abattre des
avions qui est tombé dans un parking
depuis que le Kremlin a décidé d'annexer
la région les frappes augmentent
l'ensemble bolcho
de bombardements qu'en ce moment
pourquoi il nous intimide leur
référendum n'a aucun sens pour nous de
toute façon et ça ne change rien ce
référendum s'est fait pour l'opinion
publique russe donc je ne comprends
absolument
pas pourquoi il tire
pour yak la réponse à l'annexion
prochaine ne peut être que militaire il
faut poursuivre la contre-offensive
dit-il et reconquérir ces territoires